[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
98 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am good.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I am pretty tired,
because we had to
wake up really early.
MARK MANDEL: You had to
do something at 8:00 AM.
It wasn't that bad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is
incredibly early for me.
MARK MANDEL: Not bad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I come
from a different time zone.
I was born in Barcelona,
different time zone.
So I'm still jet
lagged from that.
Yeah, still jet
lagged from there.
But anyway-- very excited,
and I am pretty excited.
But you're probably more excited
than me about this episode,
because it's about Australia.
MARK MANDEL: That was well done.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I've been practicing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we have Andrew Walker
and Graham Polley.
We're talking about, basically,
how a new region for a Google
Cloud Platform opened up in
Sydney, and the impact it's had
on the businesses and
technology people down there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and
also the things they're missing
and asking for and BigQuery.
MARK MANDEL: PMs, listen.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And then at the end we
will have a question
that comes from one
of our listeners.
It's a really cool question,
because it is about TensorFlow,
and whether it's useful
or not for linear algebra.
We use TensorFlow for
Machine Learning and AI.
Is it also useful
for other things?
So we'll answer that question.
But before that we have
our three cool things
of the week, and the first
one comes from France.
There's Raphael Simon.
She's the CTO and co-founder
of a bank named Shine.
And they explain how they
implemented the whole thing,
which is really
cool, because they
have very high availability.
They have five nines.
And they explain how all
of their technical choices,
going from Firebase, to
running their macro services
using App Engine flex with
the Google Cloud Endpoints.
And then on top of that they
talk about the database.
And the database is really cool,
because they go with Spanner.
And they explain all of
the things to the point
that they even
give you pro tips.
Saying like, you know, this
is the way we implemented,
these are the things we
learned, and stuff like that--
super cool.
Definitely worth reading.
And if, Raphael Simon,
you're listening,
you're more than invited
to join the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
I actually also like--
there was a little bit
in here talking
about basically how
he used IAM policies as well.
Being a financial
institution-- don't
want to give access to
just anybody to anything.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Kind of makes sense.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so really good to
see that they're taking
advantage of that, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, very cool.
MARK MANDEL: So next up
we have bigger machines.
We have bigger machines, so
Compute Engine machine types
now go up to 96 virtual CPUs
and 624 gigabytes of memory.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is a lot.
MARK MANDEL: That's a lot.
And don't forget
that you can always
use custom machine types.
So if our standard templates
don't necessarily work for you,
you can sit down and
choose exactly what sort
of CPUs and memory you
need for those machines.
And now you can just have
more CPU and more memory.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I wonder-- so
if you can go up to 96 CPUs,
and then you can add, I
don't know how many GPUs,
and then all of this memory.
What would you do
with a machine so big?
I really don't know what--
MARK MANDEL: Things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Like play a game?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Probably, yeah.
Probably play a game.
Cool.
And then our last
cool thing of the week
comes from the community.
Demi Ben-Ari, he wrote
a medium blog post
on what is Cloud
Dataprep, and how
to use it to prepare
your data before doing
any kind of big data processing.
It is very cool, and it is
covering a product that we
have not really talked about--
Cloud Dataprep.
And you know what?
We actually have
planned this already,
and we will have an episode
coming up soon with the product
manager from Cloud Dataprep.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and thanks to Demi,
especially because
he's a GDE as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Google
Developer Experts,
you all rule.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Awesome.
Well, Francesc,
I think it's time
to go talk to Andrew and Graham
all about this new Sydney
region.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: A conversation
with three Australians?
OK.
MARK MANDEL:
Absolutely fantastic.
So I'm very excited
to, yet again,
surround Francesc by a
bunch of Australians.
We have podcast
alumni, Graham Polley,
and one of his compatriots,
Andrew Walker, joining us today
to talk all about the region
that has recently opened up
in Sydney, Australia,
and how that's
changed things down there.
Before we get stuck into that,
though, how are you both doing?
Thank you so much
for joining us.
GRAHAM POLLEY: I'm doing great.
It's Graham here.
It's great to be back on
the podcast since last time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you for coming.
What about you, Andrew?
ANDREW WALKER: It's great to
be on my first podcast, guys,
thanks for inviting me.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Before we get stuck
into the topic at hand,
why don't we get some
background on both of you.
Graham, you've been
on the podcast before.
So, Andrew, please go first.
Tell us a little about who
you are, what do you do,
what company you work for.
ANDREW WALKER: I'm
the founder of 3wks.
We specialize in building stuff,
mostly enterprise customers
using serverless technologies.
So that's usually a combination
of web mobile gadgets, big data
quite often, Machine Learning.
We've done 190 projects
on GCP now, usually
with App Engine at the middle.
But we often use
those other things,
like the Machine Learning
API and BigQuery.
Despite the name,
usually we work
on big transformation
projects that have failed
a couple of times before.
That name, in case
someone asks, is just
about breaking it
into small chunks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
What about you, Graham?
Remind our audience who
are you and what you do.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Happy to.
So I'm Graham Polley.
I'm a software engineer based
out of Melbourne, Australia,
and I work for Shine Solutions.
Shine Solutions are an
enterprise digital consultancy.
We've got offices in
Melbourne and Sydney now.
And I'm also an official
Google Developer
Expert for Google Cloud.
Still the only one in
Australia for Cloud,
so that's quite
an honor to hold.
And yeah, I work a lot
with data and analytics
on the Google Stack.
So primarily around BigQuery,
Dataflow, Dataproc, and the ML
APIs.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, so we thought
we'd get the two of you
together, as this is something
we haven't really done before.
Recently, there was a
new Google Cloud Platform
region that has started--
that has been brought
up in Sydney, Australia.
And I sort of wanted to
talk about this impact
that that has had for both of
you in the areas in which you
work in Australia.
I thought I'd start maybe by
taking a step back a little,
and one of you can choose--
I don't know which
one-- but I want
to explain the current internet
situation in Australia.
It's a little less than ideal
for a variety of reasons.
Who wants to take this one?
I just wanted to get
some background there.
ANDREW WALKER: Yeah,
look, I'd love to do that.
So I guess the biggest
thing about Australia
is our remoteness.
People who are really
closely connected,
like in Europe and
America, are used
to having high speeds of
connectivity between point A
and point B. So, you know,
for the last 10 years,
we've been dealing
with round trip times
to either the west
coast of America,
or somewhere up in Asia,
or somewhere in Europe.
So we've had to
work around that.
And, I guess, the
second thing is
that our infrastructure here
in Australia is not great.
In the lead up to
the conversation,
Graham was saying
that he's actually
connecting over 4G just
to make this podcast,
and I'm doing exactly
the same thing
because my internet connection
at home is just so poor.
So that's something that we've
had to work around things a lot
for the last few years while we
build solutions for enterprise.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
So you were mentioning
that this is--
in your houses-- the
connectivity is not that good,
but what about the office?
As a developer, is this
something that changes
the way you write
code, specifically
cloud solutions and stuff?
ANDREW WALKER: So we do
everything in the cloud.
We're an asset-less company.
We're a serverless company.
So connectivity is huge for us.
Normally at offices it's fine.
I say normally, like
we'll get outages
during the middle of the
day sometimes at our office,
and then we all switch
to back-up on 4G.
So as a company
our biggest expense
outside airfares
and entertainment
is actually internet
connectivity.
MARK MANDEL: So I guess
then, especially with you,
Graham, you work
in big data sets,
you're not pulling
down terabytes
of data backwards and forwards?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Well, no.
A common pattern that
I normally employ
is actually bring
the code to the data,
not the data to the code--
so using tools and
services like BigQuery,
where that data is stored
currently in the US.
Writing the SQL
and UDF functions
for that is a much
better pattern,
rather than downloading massive
data sets and working locally,
or spinning up other
VMs and working there.
One of the big changes for
me with the new Sydney region
is, although BigQuery
is not there yet,
we have data flow in region.
So customers are
a lot happier now.
They're closer to the data.
They feel more secure.
So that data can be
processed and stored locally
in Australia, and
that's fantastic.
So we're spinning up Dataflow
pipelines in region there.
And that's a game
changer for us,
because it makes those
conversations a lot easier
to have with enterprises.
Especially their
security operations
and privacy, because they feel
more comfortable that the data
is now stored locally.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm curious
about what you were mentioning
about locality of data.
Is there specific
Australian policies
that make it that
you'd need to have
the data stored in the country?
Or is it more about people
just feeling more comfortable
about it?
GRAHAM POLLEY:
There's actually laws,
and it's around
data sovereignty.
So if any of the data
has PII information-- so
Personally Identifiable
Information--
that can't be shipped offshore.
That has to stay in Australia.
And that's a challenge for
us, and that's always been
a challenge for us in the past.
So that's what I mean
with the new data
center, or the new region
coming online in Sydney.
It makes those
conversations a lot easier.
We've worked around
that in the past
by applying caching to the data.
So that means we don't
have any plain text
PII in our analytics
inside our data.
So that's gotten us around
those challenges with security
and privacy in the past.
So having the new region
in Sydney, and especially
with Dataflow, it just means
that those conversations
are a lot easier to
have, because the data
is stored locally.
MARK MANDEL: Andrew, have you
had similar situations, where
before the region spun up
there were certain work arounds
you had to put in place?
ANDREW WALKER: Yeah,
look, our experience
has been slightly different.
We do less work in
government and finance,
mainly because they have some
very specific legislation,
specifically in PII
that holds them back.
We've had less
constraint, because we
avoid those in the
main, that we have
done things like administer
de-briefing systems in Google
Cloud before.
So really the core issue
for us has typically
been away from sovereignty
and more towards privacy
in most sectors.
And it hasn't been such a
large theoretical issue,
but actually, the theoretical
issues is sort of irrelevant.
Having data in
Australia just means
you don't have six months
of lead time toward a job.
That's as simple as it gets
for us-- having the region here
just means there is 10
conversations with 10
separate groups of people that
we just don't have to have
because they're not confused.
So I can give you probably
three examples of projects
that we're doing recently
here in Australia.
One for a big utility
company, for Fieldforce
in field engineers, another
one in retail, another one in--
actually, ironically
in the finance sector.
All of which have kicked
off a lot more quickly,
because they haven't had
to have those discussions
around privacy in particular.
And we've had to employ
the same sorts of issues
even in web solutions that
Graham was talking about.
So we've had to make sure
that we spend a little bit
more time on premise--
preparing data
before it goes out.
It creates some web
services for things
that we don't want to store
in the Cloud and so on.
And all of those just disappear
for everything except big data.
That whole problem has just
gone away for us on App Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So I'm wondering now--
you mentioned that one of
things that have been solved
is the locality, and the
fact that the data doesn't
leave the country, which
solves a series of problems.
Is there any other things
that the fact that Google
opened a new cloud computing
region in Australia
has fixed for you?
ANDREW WALKER: Yeah.
A good example of
this is a big project
we did for one of the
media players here.
Where we opened up
all of the content
for basically all
of their digital
and actually newspaper estates,
right across like 150 estates.
Back in those days latency
was a really big issue for us.
We've been able to avoid
latency as an issue
when it comes down to user
facing apps on App Engine,
because the latency of
the quarter of a second,
or a fifth of a second
wasn't something
that really had to be taken into
account for user experience.
But when you're
building an API you
need 30 milliseconds, 50
millisecond response times.
So we've had to use
Amazon in situations
like that in the past.
We do that project again today,
and I get to do that on GCP
now.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah, I think
the latency, the round trip
latency, is an
important one as well.
So on average, in
the past, I'd be
getting maybe 250,
300 milliseconds,
so now I'm seeing 10
to 15 milliseconds,
which is fantastic.
Yeah, you can go to-- do you
guys know the GCP ping website?
It's really cool.
The GCP ping, and now
for the Sydney region
I'm seeing even sometimes
below 10 milliseconds.
It's fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Nice, that is awesome.
So, Andrew, you
mentioned that you
were using Amazon for some
other things, and that is true.
Before Google
Cloud had a region,
Amazon was already there.
So why using Google Cloud?
Is there any benefit or
advantage that made you use it?
ANDREW WALKER: Yeah, absolutely.
We're fast becoming
100% GCP, especially
with the region opening
up in Australia.
And that's not because--
you know, we're
actually not resellers.
We make our money out of
building stuff for people.
So it really comes
down to money.
We had a client onstage at the
Google Cloud Summit explaining
just how much cheaper
it is to build on GCP,
and it really just comes
down to serverless.
GCP is genuinely serverless,
whereas Amazon never really
has been-- not in
a practical sense.
They have their equivalent
to Cloud Functions,
but they don't have an
equivalent to App Engine.
With the richness of
services that that gives,
it's just such an
exciting technology.
And I do also agree with
Graham that BigQuery
and supporting
services is just--
it's got to be the crown jewel.
We get 50% of our
speed benefits.
We generally move 50%
faster than anyone else.
We usually deliver
somewhere between a quarter
to a half of the budget
of our competitors.
And 50% of that speed
advantage comes just
from the serverless
cloud, and that's really
what GCP is for us.
We have the whole
deploy on Monday thing.
So we're not spending
four weeks as we
have done on some of
our Amazon projects
just waiting, having discussions
around infrastructure.
OK, it might be in the
cloud, but you're still
engineering it, which
is really painful when
you have to go back to that
from a serverless world.
The scale to zero thing
as quoted by our customers
who have got 200 environments.
The fact that so many
of those scale to zero
makes a massive
operational cost impact.
We're talking in some cases
10% of the cost of the Amazon
infrastructure.
So these things make
a massive difference.
So I guess the one final thing
that gives us a huge speed
difference in just
development is
the local emulation on the SDK.
So the ability for
a developer to run
locally without having
to be their own DevOps
person, without having
to setup Tomcat,
without having to setup
MySQL on the local machine.
It's really hard
to overestimate.
It's such a phenomenal thing,
and one of the key things
that brings us back to
App Engine every time.
MARK MANDEL: Out of curiosity,
because I'm actually
surprised Francesc
hasn't asked, Andrew,
what language are you
writing on App Engine?
ANDREW WALKER: So
we write in Java.
We're not particularly
wedded to Java,
but we choose one language
across the company
to give us that scale.
We like type safety,
so we've chosen Java,
and that killer feature of--
I think, it's only about three
languages that support it--
of having the local emulation,
100% local likely emulation.
Even with task queues, you
know of all the key elements
of the things that we're
using on an everyday basis.
So one day we'll probably
move to Node as the backend
when we get type safety,
and that works well for us.
But for the moment most of the
projects we do are in Java.
GRAHAM POLLEY: I think another
thing worth pointing out
is per second billing now.
That's huge.
Right, so that was
announced last week,
so we now have
per second billing
on Google Cloud Platform.
That's going to save our
customers a lot of money,
especially for me writing
Dataflow jobs and batch
pipelines, and that saves
our customers and clients
a lot of money.
It's fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So, Graham, something that you
mentioned a couple, or even
a bunch of times, was the
fact that there's no BigQuery.
So let's talk about that.
GRAHAM POLLEY: I love
talking about BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know, I know.
So tell us a little bit not
only why you want BigQuery--
I assume that
BigQuery is important.
But since BigQuery is not there,
but you are a Google Developer
Expert partly because of the
job that you do BigQuery, what
is your experience using
BigQuery from a region that
doesn't have it yet?
GRAHAM POLLEY: OK, so using
BigQuery is a no-brainer.
It's just a phenomenal product,
and Andrew touched on it
already.
For me, and I think
Andrew will agree with me,
it's the jewel in the crown
for Google Cloud Platform.
There's no product like it.
It's the speed at which
you can grind true data.
It's the scale.
It's the ease of use.
It's got a good REST API.
It's now got standard SQL.
It's just a fantastic product.
We've been using
BigQuery since 2012,
2013, so quite a few years.
And we've been in Telstra,
which is Australia's largest
ISP in TeleCom.
And we've worked around the
issues of not having BigQuery
in region, and I
touched on this earlier,
by hashing a lot of
the PII information--
or actually just stripping
it out completely.
That keeps their security
and privacy teams happy.
There's another little
trick that you can do,
and maybe not a lot of
people know about this,
and you will take a
hit on performance.
But what you can actually
do is you can still
store your data locally.
So what you could do, because
we have the region in Sydney,
you could store
your data in GCS--
so locally in region--
and use federated
sources in BigQuery.
Because BigQuery does
everything in memory,
so it's gonna pull that
data, churn through it
in memory in either
the EU or the US.
But that data is
not stored locally,
so it's only being
processed offshore.
Now whether that gets
through security constraints,
and it's something
that enterprises
are comfortable with,
I don't know yet.
I haven't tested it out
with large enterprises yet,
but it's a little trick
that maybe people can employ
to get around those issues.
But I think the
massive benefit would
be getting BigQuery in region.
So the benefit there would
be a lot more enterprise,
and government,
and customers would
be willing to adopt BigQuery
into their workloads
if they knew it was in region.
And that, again, comes
down to having PII--
it's all about PII--
and if it was in region they
would be a lot more comfortable
with that.
So fingers crossed if we
can build enough use cases
and show Google the value of
having BigQuery in region,
and maybe it will come
online in the near future.
So I'm holding out for that one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Everything I can say
is that the product
managers for BigQuery,
they do listen to the podcast.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
That's good to hear.
ANDREW WALKER: So, guys,
I wouldn't mind also
adding a little bit to that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, go for it.
ANDREW WALKER: I would agree
with everything Graham says.
I love BigQuery for the
bigness of BigQuery.
I think that one of the other
strengths of the platform that
gets overlooked a
lot, actually, is
that we have this phrase
in three weeks that says,
"Serverless means Monday."
The fact that I can get
the stuff up and running,
and literally get like
a terabyte of data
up, on Monday morning,
and incorporate this
into a solution into some AI ML.
Even just the simplest thing of
just treating it as a reporting
engine is amazingly cool.
When you can stand
that thing up--
and it's been stood
up, in fact, for you--
it's just part of your
project and is immediately
available to your project.
It's also easy to
underestimate that.
So normally if I'm having
a conversation with someone
about how to report
on something,
again, it's a binary thing.
It's not, oh, it'll
add a couple of days.
If there's some
non-serverless element then
it's going to add months.
It adds like two months to
talk about it, two months
to agree on something.
So the fact that we
use BigQuery by default
as our standard
reporting engine means
that we can provide a whole
bunch of functionality
around, say, a mobile solution,
or around a web based solution.
That you wouldn't be
able to do if you're
having to setup a local, or
even a partially local solution.
So I would also say that that
is a big factor for bringing
BigQuery to Australia.
At the moment, if I do
have to work around things,
if do have to process
data in some way,
if I have to remove
keys internally,
I immediately have to involve
a whole bunch of people
who are resource constrained.
And as soon as I do
that, I'm into months.
We had a recent project
at the University
where we just had to make
a small change exactly
like what Graham was
describing, but we
had to wait for a team of
people to do that internally,
and it took literally four
weeks just to talk to them.
So that whole
"serverless means Monday"
thing I couldn't overemphasize.
It's so cool being able to
stand it up immediately.
We write code.
We deploy Monday.
We report Tuesday.
Customers use it on Wednesday
to do real reporting.
And I think the final thing
there is the Data Studio.
As Data Studio
matures, that is going
to be such a cool tool for
us and for our clients.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
So I guess looking forward
I'll be kind of curious to hear
how that now there is
a region in Sydney,
how has that changed the plans
for what you're planning,
develop looking forward.
ANDREW WALKER: The biggest
change for us is that--
if I could put it
really bluntly--
is we're going to let our
partnership with Amazon lapse.
Been doing less and less work,
and since the Sydney region
came on, it's hard to
imagine a situation where
we would put our
hand on heart say
that we're doing the right
thing with our client's money.
By doubling the budget, I
mean that's literally what
we're going to be doing, right.
So for us, the most
fundamental change
is that we're going to sort of
become de facto until there's
another serverless offering like
App Engine and the supporting
tools.
So that's part of it.
But the other part
is that we're going
to go after some of the
clients that we weren't that
excited about, and I think
government is a good one
that Graham mentioned.
We've done some great
work in government,
but they just didn't--
I guess, scared of the cloud.
And in some cases
not rightly so-- but
it doesn't matter if
they're still scared.
So that makes a big difference
for us in terms of the sectors
that we are going after.
Government comes back
onto the radar for us.
MARK MANDEL: And you, Graham?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah,
for me at least,
and for working for Shine, I can
see the momentum growing now.
So it's really gaining
traction, especially
with the new region
coming online.
There's a lot more interest
in Google Cloud Platform.
And the commitment that Google
have offered for the partner
ecosystem-- we can see that
that's starting to build out.
And GCP-- it really offers
some compelling services
to Australian customers that you
don't get on any of the rest.
We are platform agnostic.
So we work on both platforms.
But the differentiator that
I see as a Google Developer
Expert is definitely
the data analytics side
of things and the machine
learning on AI on GCP.
So absolutely it opens
a lot more doors for us
in terms of-- we can go
after big enterprises
and government-end customers.
Because we don't need to
have those hard conversations
with security teams about
data being shipped offshore.
We can now say it can be
stored in region in Sydney.
So it's definitely--
it's an exciting time.
There's a lot of potential
for Shine, more customers,
and we're really,
really excited about it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Well, we're kind of
running out of time,
but is there anything else other
than that the fact that you
want BigQuery in Sydney?
Anything else you'd like to add?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Don't forget
Cloud Functions with BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
GRAHAM POLLEY: And the ML APIs--
that would be cool.
I think one thing
to maybe give a plug
for is Melbourne is
having its first ever
Google Devfest in October.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So we're
really excited about that.
Mark, I'm going to
see you there, right?
You're going to be presenting?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I booked
my flights and everything.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Brilliant.
I'll be presenting, too.
I think Andrew is sending some
of the guys from 3wks along.
They're going to be
showcasing some stuff.
That's another
indicator of how GCP now
is really getting attention.
We've never had a
Devfest in Melbourne.
This is the first one, and
it's a really exciting time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I guess it's also
important to mention
that you're also
involved with a Google
developers group, Cloud,
in Melbourne.
GRAHAM POLLEY: That's right.
So I'm one of the
organizers of GDG Cloud
Melbourne, the Meetup.
We spun that about
three months ago,
and the growth is phenomenal.
So we already have--
I think we're touching
on 500 members
already after just
three months, and we've
got some great talks,
great presenters.
We're getting a consistent
turnout at the meetup,
so it's really, really exciting.
And getting Googlers to come
and speak, and talk about Google
Cloud Platform,
it's great for me,
it's great for the community.
And I'm seeing it first hand.
I'm really seeing the community
starting to flourish now.
I ran GCP, and that's a
really great thing to see,
because I've been working on
GCP for four, five years now.
And a little bit lonely
and quiet at the start,
but now it's changing.
And I really think that stands
for the new region as well.
It's fantastic.
MARK MANDEL: Andrew, do you
have anything else to add?
ANDREW WALKER: Yeah, I
would echo those sentiments.
Actually, Graham's encouraged
us to create the Sydney Cloud
Meetup for the Google
Developers Group, which
we are in the process of doing.
But I would say,
look, five and a half,
six years worth of
experience on App
Engine and the
supporting technologies--
I've never seen as
much interest as I have
in the last two, three months.
As well as the local
region opening up,
I think it's also fair to say
that Google has been putting
a lot more effort into this
region themselves-- more
people, the Cloud
Summit recently
has made a big difference.
And to put that in a
fairly sort of simple way,
we traditionally would
have a new developer
start at three weeks, and they
hadn't had any real experience.
They hadn't even deployed
an app onto App Engine,
because it's unusual.
They are used to using
local tools on machines.
When they first look
at it, it's like, OK,
I'm not sure what this thing is.
But recently we've
been getting people
through the interview process
who have had that experience.
And I put that down to the fact
that there's a Sydney region,
there's excitement around
it, and there's energy
being put into it from Google.
So we're really looking to be--
looking forward to being part
of the community here in Sydney
and also in Melbourne.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, Graham,
Andrew, again, thank
you so much for coming
and hanging out,
always good to have
more Australians.
I really appreciate you both
taking the time to talk to us
today about the Sydney
region, and what
you both do with both the
companies you work at.
ANDREW WALKER: Thank you, guys.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Thanks, guys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thanks so
much, to both Andrew and Graham,
for taking the time today to
talk a little bit about all
of the things that have
changed since there's
a new region in Sydney.
And also for sharing
all of their requests,
which are really good.
I'm sure there's PMs
listening somewhere.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure.
Yes, and thank you very
much to Graham and Andrew.
Continuing on, why don't we talk
about our question of the week?
This week we are talking
about TensorFlow.
Now, I don't know a huge
amount about TensorFlow,
but we got a question in from
one of our wonderful listeners.
I'm going to mispronounce
his name most likely,
Sy-mohn A-kuh-shee-nuh,
possibly?
A-kuh-chee-nuh?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm
going to say it's See-mohn
A-kuh-chee-nuh or
A-kuh-chee-nuh.
MARK MANDEL: You're probably--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm not very
sure, but something like that.
MARK MANDEL: I'll just
somehow Australianify it.
It'll be fine.
But he asks an
interesting question about
whether TensorFlow is good
for general math computation,
like doing linear algebra,
or even just adding stuff
together.
Can you use it for that
kind of stuff, Francesc?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So the
quick answer is, yes,
and it totally makes sense.
Because if you think
about it, Machine Learning
is basically about matrix
multiplication, mostly.
Some functions on top, but it's
mostly matrix multiplication.
And linear algebra is also very
often a matrix multiplication,
or operations of a matrix--
like the product,
and multiplication
and decomposition,
or stuff like that.
So it totally makes
sense that if something
is good for Machine
Learning, it should be
pretty good for linear algebra.
Now, the cool thing
that I didn't expect
is that if you compare
TensorFlow versus NumPy,
TensorFlow is incredibly
faster than NumPy.
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And I am not sure
if it is because TensorFlow
uses the GPU, which it does,
unless you're running it on a
MacBook with the latest version
of TensorFlow which, reasons.
But in general
you're going to get
incredibly faster computations,
just because you're
using all the GPU.
And I will add a link
to a specific article
where they compare NumPy,
to Theano, to TensorFlow--
Theano is a different
library that
provides similar things
to TensorFlow really.
And you will see that
both Theano and TensorFlow
are almost exponentially faster
than NumPy for most operations.
It is pretty amazing
for things like finding
the minimum, or the sum,
and stuff like that.
TensorFlow is basically
the whole line
is basically flat
on how long it takes
to find the sum of a matrix.
No matter if it's 500
elements or 5,000 elements,
it's still pretty much the
same, which is really good.
So if you're doing linear
algebra I'd say try TensorFlow.
It is really simple--
most operations
have the same name--
both NumPy and TensorFlow.
So it's not very hard to move
from one way to the other.
And at the end
you're going to get
code that executes way faster--
so definitely worth trying.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, that sounds
good, and thank you
for providing that answer--
I learned something new today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Then
you're very welcome.
MARK MANDEL: That's good.
All right, cool.
Are you headed off
anywhere special?
Doing anything
cool, JustForFunc?
For
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yes.
By the time this
episode comes out,
I will have the second
part of code review
that I did on JustForFunc.
It's a code review for
a URL shortener, which
is the second part
of that, and other
than that I am going to
fly to London very soon.
I will be speaking at
Velocity Com in London, which
is on Wednesday, the 18th.
And then the day before,
on Tuesday the 17th,
I'll be speaking at the
Go Meetup in London.
So that's Tuesday, Wednesday.
On Thursday, I will be speaking
at the Cloud Summit in Paris.
And then on Friday,
probably I'll
just go and enjoy Paris, because
I think it's a beautiful city.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds like
a reasonable thing to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And then I'll come
back to San Francisco,
and then I'll go back
to Paris for a third go.
Yes.
Planning.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: What about me?
So I will be heading off to
Australia later this month--
heading up there for the
Melbourne International Games
Week.
I'll be speaking at Game
Connect Asia Pacific,
but hanging out at
Unite and PAX Australia.
And just before that I
will be also speaking
at the GDG Melbourne
Summit, which I believe
is actually sold out,
which is pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So I think it is
time to say goodbye,
but before we say goodbye
there's a couple of things.
I'm going to repeat this over
and over from now on, which
is, please subscribe.
And, no, that's more
YouTube, but please
let us know what you
think about the podcast.
Find us on iTunes, or whatever
you find in these podcasts,
and leave comments,
leave five stars.
And leave a review-- we will
definitely check those out,
so let us know what you think.
And send us more
questions of the week--
specifically, we have
an episode coming,
episode number 100 which is
really, really important.
We will be
interviewing Vint Cerf.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, my god.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Very, very excited.
So Vint Cerf for those that
don't know, shame on you.
If you don't know
who Vint Cerf is,
he's one of the so-called,
fathers of the internet.
And basically we're going to
be asking all of the questions
that you want to ask him.
So in order to send those
questions please tweet to us
@GCPPodcast with the
#askvint V-I-N-T.
For those that don't know how
to write their name, right Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I know how
to write his name now.
It's fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
send us your questions--
we're really, really excited.
We have a bunch of
questions already,
but please keep on sending
them-- they're really good.
MARK MANDEL: I
want to know where
he gets all his amazing suits.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Store.
MARK MANDEL: He's
always so well-dressed.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: He's incredibly
well-dressed-- he makes me feel
like I should dress way better.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So Yeah.
I'm so excited
about that episode.
But anyway, send
us your questions
for Vint with #askvint,
or send us your questions
for anything else, because
we're preparing more episodes.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely
well Francesc,
thank you so much for joining
me for yet another week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you, Mark.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: And we'll
see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]